bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 17
janvier l'année 2018 des solistes de la
vidéo débute avec beethoven savent du
philips soliste depuis 2003 envie de son
complice françois frédéric guy et
interprète rousseau n'a fait variations
du compositeur allemand décembre 1999 au
fin fond de la picardie michel alonso
bibliothécaire et totalisé paris donc du
passage à l'an 2000 il sera victime d'un
punk et se rendre à aventuriers une
toute nouvelle création découvrir le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles à 30 ans il a été lancé en
1987 et il travaille sur le patrimoine
musical des xviie et xviiie siècles
une cérémonie se tenait hier soir au
ministère de la culture un violoncelle
un piano et beethoven ce samedi
l'auditorium de trappes va résonner des
sonates et variations du compositeur
allemand les artistes xavier phillips
solistes de lavilledieu depuis 2003 et
françois frédéric guy pour nous en
parler avait faim bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président de l'apn est ce qu'une
association pour la promotion de la
musique sur saint quentin en yvelines et
donc les deux musiciens vont nous faire
du beethoven ils vont nous faire de
beethoven tout à fait alors enfin en
fait c'est très intéressant parce que
beethoven bon on connaît bien sûr ses
symphonies on connaît ses concertos on
connaît aussi des saunas de les sonates
pour piano sont très connus les sonates
pour violon et piano ce fameux son
attaque redire qu une pure merveille
mais en revanche les sonates pour piano
et violoncelle sont peu connus très très
peu connues est en fait grâce à xavier
phillips qui
et un des piliers de celui de la bio
depuis maintenant l'année 2003 il a
proposé en fait de monter ce concert
avec comme vous dites son complice
françois frédéric guy qui est un
pianiste extraordinaire qui s est un
spécialiste de beethoven poids la ville
a donc joué les concertos avec là dessus
à lille il a joué des sonates pour piano
et c'est un grand spécialiste et donc
c'est un bonheur de les voir se
rencontrer deux talents pareils et ce
soir là ils vont jouer trois sonates
l'a3 et l'a4 l'a5 et l'a4 et l'a5 sont
issus de l'opus 102 comme on les nomme
apparemment ce serait le plus abouti ce
serait le plus abouti c'est voilà c'est
en fait dans l'ordre
donc les opus se sont fait l'ordre de
création des oeuvres est en fait le donc
le plus la salle numéro 3 par exemple
opus 69 a été bien sûr composé avant est
en fait les cartes et les cinq ont été
composées en même temps c'est vrai il
était en pleine maturité et
l'a5 et qu'on serré comme l'a un peu le
chef-d'oeuvre
c'est de ces deux cessna de ce 5 sauna
on peut pas jouer les cinq mais on aura
déjà le plaisir de jouer les deux voies
la reine notamment vraiment la sonatt 5
qui était une pure merveille et l'agent
prévoit justement la 125 on en parle un
extrait il a été enregistré dans un
album commun pour les deux artistes en
le
[Musique]
alors on a parlé des sonates
il ya aussi des variations ce soir là
sur la flûte enchantée de mozart
absolument dire qu'en fait comme souvent
des compositeurs font des variations on
a eu droit par exemple aux variations de
fait par tchaikovsky pour violoncelle et
orchestre sur un air de paganini et la
bête of fighters et a fait des
variations pour violoncelle piano piano
pied sur les airs de la plus tranchante
et donc c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire parce qu'on est quand
même de ce sont deux mots c'est quand
même assez différents les voit pas du
tout dans le même lit il était même très
proche puisque quand même méthodes et
rien que devant que mozart décède et
s'il ya une espèce de ponk et je trouve
très très intéressante entre ces deux
compositeurs
alors ma différents types différents
extraits papageno tous ces airs là et
c'est amusant et de les entendre par ses
immenses artistes
justement ces immenses artistes on
disait que xavier phillips qui est
soliste de la ville depuis 2003 il est
aussi un disciple de rostropovitch qui
fut une figure majeure du xxème siècle
tout à fait tout à fait et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a dieu qu'on a du
mal à imaginer
dieu sait s'il ya eu des violoncellistes
qui ceux qui ont été proches de notre
politique mais lui l'a vu à une
rencontre très forte entre xavier
phillips et rostropovitch et à tel point
que
quand rostropovitch a dirigé à new york
le concerto pour violoncelle de
forget a qu il a dirigé en fait leur
caisse de new york
rostropovitch et c'est xavier phillips
qui a fait le seul soliste au
violoncelle ce qui est quand même une
sacrée référence
alors on a un peu pris par le temps tout
à fait ce que demandant de préciser on
va rappeler la date samedi 20 janvier
c'est à 18 heures à 18 heures avec les
hommes de l'école de musique de tram on
voit la saison est faite et le prochain
concert chez a lancé le 10 février alors
voilà donc le 10 février alors là on
retrouve montrait très rapidement votre
clavier philips donc une une pointure
vous écoutez radio classique vous
l'entendez régulièrement il sera avec un
autre de ses complices est un soliste de
la vidéo si eric le sage un piano et
puis nous aurons une jeune clarinettiste
mariam adam et donc on aura des sonates
pour piano trio sonate piano devinettes
et c est là aussi ça va être un grand
moment
merci merci beaucoup on change de sujet
on part au théâtre avec michel alonso
qui a la cinquantaine et qui est un
bibliothécaire municipale et craint le
bug de l'an 2000 c'est lui qui va la
voir il se met à rêver être un
aventurier alors la queue d'âne la
cordonnerie revisite actuellement le
célèbre don quichotte 7 au théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
regarder métilde weyergans et samuel
hercule bonjour vous êtes tous les deux
les metteurs en scène dans la peau de
don quichotte et vous nous emmener au
décembre 1999
oui exactement dans une petite ville
dont on oublie toujours le nom quelque
part en picardie on retrouve un
bibliothécaire est un petit peu effrayé
à l'idée de ce passage à l'an 2000 et
qui a peur du bugue haution on découvre
toute la vie d'une bibliothèque une
ville peut dire est simple et qui va se
trouver chamboulés et transformé par la
suite et donc avec le titre dans la peau
de don quichotte on comprend vite que
c'est une adaptation du livre de michel
cervantès ouais alors une adaptation
beaucoup disent que le livre c'est peu
plus 1500 pages et là on a un spectacle
qui fait à peu près une heure 35 40
donc c'est plus de s'être inspiré du
personnage que tout le monde connaît par
contre très peu de gens vivre l'oeuvre
en entier et
et donc là une idée c'était plutôt de
faire effectivement don quichotte on
sait que c'est un personnage qui iraient
beaucoup critiqué par teen certains l
appellent un fou d'autres au contraire
trouvent qu'il est plutôt un rêveur donc
voilà on est à mi chemin entre plein de
choses
on avait envie de faire effectivement
travaillé autour de ce hard
est-ce que ont fait basculer nos
personnages m'ont donnée qui comprend
qu'il se croit être dans la peau de don
quichotte et l'idée c'était de se dire
le point de départ de notre travail est
ce que est ce que c'est vivre dans ses
bibliothèques d'une vitrine monotone il
habite tout seul et on comprend bien que
sa vie n'est pas très marrante
est ce que c'est ça que tu es plus fous
de cette routine l'acquis voilà qui sent
sans saveur ou est-ce que c'est
finalement de tomber dans la folie et se
croire être ailleurs voilà donc c'était
un peu tout le cheminement un peu l'idée
du spectacle et comment vous mettez en
scène alors 7,7
ben nous on travaille avec avec de
l'image et du son
il interprète un film en direct donc on
a tourné un film
donc l'animal l'image est la base de
notre travail et après autour de ça
justement c'est on travaille avec eux on
a deux musiciens qui ont fait la
création musicale est puni de zoom sur
scène avec aussi un acteur qui
interprète le personnage de don
quichotte et à bangui justement l'idée
c'est qu'on a un peu à différentes
parties différents moments de la vie de
ce michel alonso qui qui évolue en
direct au plateau cette matière live et
déjà création comment ça se joue sur
scène vous avez peut-être quelques
libertés pour vous pouvez prendre
quelques toute liberté où tout est bas
pas vraiment c'est vraiment une
partition qui est extrêmement écrite qui
est dictée par le timing du film qui est
projetée et donc qui est pas à mener a
énormément évolué alors évidemment que
chaque représentation est unique et à
saveur et sa particularité mais on est
on est tenu à interpréter une partition
extrêmement précise
c'est très important dans notre travail
la précision c'est pour ça que tu as des
répétitions assez intense le temps de
deux voilà d'être très donner cette
partition des répétitions intenses qui
ont pris fin il ya peu j'imagine fait
que vous répétez encore ce que la
première a eu lieu hier 7 janvier mai au
théâtre nations travaillent encore là on
est là elle est encore tout et on sera
là demain tôt c'est du spectacle vivant
donc les spectacles usant même si nous
effectuons un travail de base était le
film qui lui est immuable plus est
mais sinon le reste les choses se
peaufine sa fille et ses moments de la
dentelle pour la maintenance et c'est de
continuer à
c'est ça qui est beau au théâtre c'est
que les choses évoluent quelque chose se
transforme on voit donc oui encore en
train de travailler
vous le disiez un petit peu en amont
vous jouez tous les deux y'a que vous et
le troisième personnage vous jouez sur
les costumes vous jouez sur les paroles
comme vous faites les changements de
surtout sur l'interprétation que c'est
ça qui nous amusent justement c'est
d'interpréter mois auparavant dans ce
spectacle traite aussi des rôles
d'hommes vocalement quoi puisque en
soutien on les voit à l'image de puits
et
donc voilà ça c'est que la maison s'est
laissé deux sets de rentrer dans une
histoire tout notre travail les autour
de ça c'est rentrer dans une histoire
alors que les choses sont fabriqués en
direct plus ou moins devant les gens en
tout cas toute la bande son fabricant
toute la bande son on veut dire toute la
vie parce que ces images sans son peu
évocatrice ou en tout cas elles peuvent
pas c'est vraiment le son qui leur donne
vie et donc voilà ça c'est la base même
travail quoi donc ça se passe autour de
ça c'est une oeuvre à découvrir
peut-être en famille à faire oui c'est
toujours difficile de donner un âge là
en tout cas
on a dit à partir de 12 ans parce que
deux ans on est capable de voir beaucoup
de choses et que voilà mais c'est pas
destination enfin c'est à destination de
tous après faut bien donner mes limites
parce que sur la durée sur les sols et
les problèmes évoqués éventuellement on
sent même d'un spectacle voilà donc en
tout cas effectivement à partir de 12
ans c'est possible je vais faire un
petit mot sur ce la cordonnerie qu'est
votre compagnie ce que vous créez
régulièrement à partir d'oeuvres comme
sa célèbre vous il ya eu à me l'être
blanche-neige peut-être oui oui mais il
ya deux ans blanche-neige de la chute du
mur de berlin mais on s'est beaucoup
inspiré des contes aussi d'oeuvres
littéraires on avait donc adapté à
hamlet
on aime beaucoup cette idée
le public vienne en sachant un peu en
croyant savoir entendre ce qu'il va voir
et puis comme on détourne beaucoup les
choses on entre on essaie de réinventer
dans les comptes ya beaucoup de cette
idée c'est très court les compliqué il
ya beaucoup de place et ça nous ça nous
intéresse beaucoup d'avoir ça comme
matériaux principaux et c'est un peu
moins le cas dans don quichotte dans le
sens où ces neuf qui est en fait on
connaît le personnage on connaît
l'histoire des moulins mais à part ça
grosso modo quand on pose la question à
100 personnes et on a 95 qui connaissent
pas vraiment ce livre qui est pourtant
des plus lus au monde face à une énigme
totale tête et est resté au monde et
donc voilà c'est sûr que on aime bien
travailler sur l'inconscient collectif
la connaissance qu'ont les spectateurs
c'est assez amusant parce que ça crée
des décalages et puis ça permet de
partir avec un quelque chose en commun
merci beaucoup à tous les deux alors
vous jouez dans la peau de don quichotte
au théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'au samedi 20 janvier et
le 18 le public pour aller à votre
rencontre
merci maguy marin chorégraphe française
questionne la place de l'homme dans le
monde
samedi 13 janvier sa compagnie était au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines elle présentait but
une farandole une farandole mccabe
horrible c'est d'en regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des danseurs parti pour un drôle de
voyage à travers les époques
maguy marin questionne la relation aux
autres la relation à soi à l'impulsion
ressenti et donne naissance à beat c'est
le vraiment de métaux de base
mais c'est vrai que c'est à partir de
laquelle peut se composer les choses ça
veut dire que ce soit cette unité qui
tout seul n'est rien et selon la
rapidité qui a rajouté de l'information
de la rythmique les choses prennent un
sens c'est plutôt dans ce sens là qu'il
faudrait la voir la chorégraphe entraîne
danseurs et spectateurs dans une
farandole macabre on ressort une
certaine violence et un questionnement
sur la misogynie ou le traitement des
personnes vu comme faible
c'est difficile d'en parler avec la
fleur à la bouche un des gaules ans et
c'est vrai qu'il ya sa demande de notre
une certaine hargne pour condamner comme
dan s un peu gnangnan de dire ça nous
met pour porter cette réflexion en tout
cas fr créé un mouvement pas une
dimension mais c'est la même chose en
fait les mentions c'est un mouvement qui
est un mouvement dans les spectateurs
une rythmique crescendo appuyée par la
musique obsédante de charles aubry une
oeuvre intense pour s'interroger sur le
vivre ensemble en société
[Musique]
et pour découvrir le parcours et
l'univers de cette chorégraphe a rendez
vous à ne pas manquer à la bibliothèque
universitaire de l'ue vs qu maguy marin
sera en conversation publique le jeudi
25 janvier on le connaissait surtout
rappeur il est aussi comédien kery james
organise un face à face un gland de deux
france qui s'ignore une joute oratoire
avec yannik landrein extraits lorsque
dos bon oeil aux a plongé dans le trafic
de drogue entre en guerre pour des
raisons strictement pécuniaires et que
cette guerre abouti à la mort de l'un
d'entre eux est ce l'état qui fournit
larmes à l'assassin est ce l'état qui
lui ordonne ou presque on doit malgré
lui sur la détente
il y a trente ans le cvb été lancée
c'est un bébé c'est pour le centre de
musique baroque de versailles en 1987
ministère de la culture lance une
mission re découvrir et valoriser le
patrimoine musical français des xviie et
xviiie siècles
ce mardi 16 janvier nécessaire de la
culture a célébré ses trois décennies
l'occasion pour nous de faire un point
sur cette histoire benoît dratwicki
boussouar soit alors vous êtes directeur
artistique au cmb et vous êtes arrivé en
2001 trente ans de travail parce qu'on
fait les trente ans cette année trente
ans de valorisation et 30 ans de musique
oui avant moi ça fait une vingtaine
d'années du coup que j'ai su au centre
de musique baroque de versailles
mais c'est vrai que j'ai la chance de
participer à cet anniversaire tout comme
j'avais participé aux 20 ans du centre
de musique baroque de versailles et en
2007 alors trente ans marquée par des
grands événements peut-être les grandes
journées
beaucoup d'événements mais j'allais dire
surtout marquée par une évolution
considérable à la fois du métier du
réseau et des partenaires avec lesquels
on travaille puisqu'il y a 20 ans et il
y a même encore dix ans nous travaillons
pas du tout de la même manière et c'est
surtout cette évolution qui est notable
je parle qu'est ce qui a changé
justement plus puisque les achats ce qui
a changé depuis ces dernières années
c'est
d'une part la mondialisation c'est à
dire que centre de musique baroque de
versailles aujourd'hui vraiment le
centre international de musique baroque
de versailles
et puis la deuxième chose c'est bien sûr
les nouvelles technologies le numérique
qui permettent à la fois en termes de
recherche à la fois en termes de
pédagogie mais aussi en termes de
projets artistiques de fonctionner de
manière totalement différente
c'est à dire d'autres découvertes
peut-être deux morceaux comment ça se
passe c'est à dire déjà des changes est
beaucoup plus facilement avec le reste
du monde avec les chercheurs avec les
musiciens de monter des coproductions
avec des partenaires parfois de pays
très éloignés
et puis de garder des traces de tout le
travail qui fait et d'avoir vraiment une
notion d'archivage et d'accumulation qui
permettra je l'espère aux générations
futures de profiter de tout ce travail
justement l'étranger vous l'avez signalé
pour l'année 2016 2017 ya eu quinze
concerts à l'étranger augmentent chaque
année alors c'était même quinze opéras à
l'étranger ce qui est encore plus les
ambitieux parce que des opéras se
rassemblent beaucoup de monde et
beaucoup de moyens en fait l'idée c'est
que chaque année nous identifions des
partenaires différents
ou au contraire des partenaires pérenne
avec lesquels nous construisons sur le
long terme et nous essayons surtout de
répondre aux demandes aux sollicitations
qui sont faites parce que le métier du
centre de musique baroque de versailles
c'est d'être utile aux répertoires
français et justement ça parte à vous le
présenter chaque année y avait 135
événement la saison précédente
ça se développe c'est très variable en
fait parce que les projets peuvent être
des petits projets qui tourne beaucoup
ou alors des grosses productions qui ne
sont donnés que une deux ou trois fois
mais qui demande beaucoup plus de
préparation et beaucoup plus de moyens
humains et financiers
donc en fait le nombre n'est pas
vraiment représentatif de
d'une potentielle évolution d'un
changement mais c'est vraiment ce qui
fait tout l'intérêt de notre travail
c'est que chaque saison est totalement
différente
c'est un monde différent du jeu vous
accueillait aussi visées des artistes en
résidence que vous accompagnez peut-être
alors on travaille on travaille avec des
artistes de plusieurs manières c'est
dire qu'il ya des orchestres avec
lesquels on est partenaire depuis depuis
pour certains 30 ans d'ailleurs le
concert spirituel et talents lyriques
les arts florissants
tous ces enfants qui sont spécialisés
notamment sur la musique baroque
française
et puis nous avons depuis plusieurs
années des chanteurs en résidence alors
c'est pas vraiment nous qui les
accompagnent ont c'est plutôt eux qui
nous accompagnent et qui nous proposons
d'être distribué dans les opéras ou les
concerts en france et à l'étranger
et depuis trente ans depuis trente ans
que vous redécouvrez ou fait fait
découvrir la musique baroque qu'il y en
encore à découvrir et des secrets qui se
cachent
oui alors il ya énormément de choses qui
se cache on a joué une cinquantaine
d'opéra en 30 ans sur les 700 que compte
le répertoire de l'opéra de paris à
l'époque par exemple on a dû jouer une
vingtaine de mots t'es sur plus d'un
millier et puis c'est vrai que parfois
on a des petits moments de déprime les
chercheurs ou les artistes en étant bon
on a tout fait on a tout trouvé
et puis d'un seul coup on découvre
d'autres participants ont dit mais
relisant ces sirops lisant cela et on
s'y met en fait là on est en train de
passer à côté de quelque chose
donc il ya encore vraiment beaucoup à
faire merci benoît dratwicki merci
mb c'est aussi de la recherche avec un
laboratoire ou de musicologie de la
restauration mais aussi de la formation
avec près de 140 chanteur devenu ce que
voilà bonjour bonjour ou alors vous êtes
l'administrateur de la maîtrise cent
quarante chanteurs sont formés chez vous
des jeunes chanteurs ou les plus âgés
ont 30 ans et les plus jeunes 4 ans
voilà c'est toute l'originalité du
projet de la maîtrise qui a été conçu en
fait par olivier schneebeli dès son
arrivée en 1991
l'idée de construire un choeur écoles
avec des enfants et des adultes pour
s'inspirer de la couleur du choeur de la
chapelle royale
donc effectivement on forme chaque année
à peu près 140 enfants tous les
champions 140 jeunes chanteurs pardon
tous les ans qui vont de l'âge de 4 ans
au jardin musical jusqu'à la formation
professionnelle des adultes
justement les enfants eux restent
presque dans un cadre loisirs mais pas
tant que ça parce que vous chantez à
l'extérieur oui alors c'est vrai pour
les enfants c'est un cadre loisirs tant
qu'ils seront sur le hors temps scolaire
mais dès le ce1 ils commencent à rentrer
dans les classes à horaires aménagés
c'est à dire une formation om vocal
musical beaucoup plus intense et puis à
partir du collège là ils font de grandes
productions avec le choeur école et ils
ont la chance de côtoyer les plus grands
artistes instrumentistes solistes en
concert vous avez précisé le nom de
celui qui dirige cette maîtrise vivier
schneebeli 91 c'est quasiment le début
du mvv une évolution peut-être dans la
formation de ces jeunes et ces adultes
c'est vrai alors même si effectivement
tout le projet de contenus à la fois
pédagogique et le projet musical a été
contenu par olivier il a aussi
accompagné tout au long de ces années
vers un certain nombre
solution de mutation et je pense en
particulier à tous les partenariats
pédagogiques que l'on a établi avec un
certain nombre de conservatoire qui sont
vraiment des associations extrêmement
riche musicalement intellectuellement
avec le conservatoire de paris saclay à
orsay avec le crr de versailles et puis
plus récemment avec le pont supérieur de
paris boulogne billancourt et c'est vrai
qu'avec ces établissements qui forment
en particulier des instrumentistes dans
le domaine baroque
nous avons des collaborations de
formation et projets musicaux qui sont
tout à fait passionnante et qui
permettent de diffuser encore
aujourd'hui le baroque exact que ça
s'arrête pas alors les trente ans vous
travaillez sur sa diffusion elle passe
par les concerts des pages et des
chantres tournée en france à l'étranger
par les enregistrements discographiques
aussi qui sont un des moyens aujourd'hui
bien sûr où les plus faciles pour
diffuser très largement cette musique de
répertoire vous le disais la
professionnalisation parce que depuis 89
vous avez eu 120 choristes et solistes
formés et 80% sont encore dans le métier
voilà c'est à dire si on dénombre
effectivement tous les adultes qu'on a
formé en tant que personnes
individuelles depuis l'origine de la
maîtrise c'est représente même à peu
près 150 personnes et notre taux
d'insertion professionnelle puisque on
mène des enquêtes régulières à l'issue
de leur formation et de près de 90%
donc on est très fier de ça parce que on
peut dire qu'aujourd'hui dans les
ensembles de musique baroque et
ensembles vocaux classique au sens large
on retrouve un nombre extrêmement
important d'anciens étudiants de la
maîtrise du cmv est depuis 30 ans qu'est
ce que chante la maîtrise est bien la
mission de la maîtrise le coeur de sa
mission c'est vraiment la musique
française des xviie et xviiie siècles et
en particulier tout le répertoire sacré
de la chapelle royale mais aussi celui
qui a été composé pour les cathédrales
pour les collégiales en france et c'est
vrai que c'est un chantier sans fin
j'irai parce que tous les ans on re
découvre de nouveaux compositeurs
là par exemple grâce au cnrs et au crr
de paris le mois prochain on va
contribuer à la redécouverte de
pierre-louis polio le maître de chapelle
de la cathédrale de beauvais au milieu
du xviiie siècle et on va faire
découvrir au public des oeuvres qu'ils
n'avaient jamais
et interprété depuis le milieu du xviiie
merci donné son aval à bout
et on retrouve notre rendez vous
réguliers le coup de coeur cinéma celui
de cette semaine c'est bertrand plisnier
les coupes coup de coeur du cinéma
décédé à cette semaine c'est the big
lebowski un film des frères coen sorti
en 1998 sur lequel on fera une
ciné-conférence c'est à dire qu'on
viendra apporter des éléments de
compréhension sur ce film un petit peu
foutraque un petit peu loufoque une
histoire donc de ce personnage qui
acquittent ou échapper
en particulier un tapis
qui est souillée par les gens au début
du film et ce personnage joué par jeff
bridges de jude va se retrouver à
essayer d'être compensés pour son papy
voilà une drôle d'idée qui lui arrive et
qui nous embarque dans un film très
étrange moitié comédie moitié film de
détective
enfin voilà au musée on vous laisse re
découvrir ce film la séance unique ce
vendredi à 20h45 au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa et puis on se retrouvera dans
deux semaines pour découvrir un autre
film d'un autre réalisateur jack burton
enfin les aventures de jack burton dans
les griffes du mandarin de john
carpenter par eon ciné conférences où on
essaiera de vous apporter des éléments
de compréhension sur le film tout en
s'amusant
une très très grande comédie très
méconnue de big john john carpenter
à très bientôt au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
alors si c'est pour protéger jack ralite
aller chez jack burton ans qu'ils nous
avons touché une dette envers lui
c'est un homme d'un grand courage au
prisme d'elancourt on parle de rupture
eric a fondé l'agencé rupture à domicile
il est mandaté par hippolyte pourront
prague est qu'il est en fait autre que
son grand amour
un trio amoureux joué par olivier sitruk
and planté et benoît se laisse regarder
on peut rater son histoire et
réussissent à audio quand quelqu'un
qu'on aime ou on n'aime pas on le hait
c'est compliqué je suis presque telle
envie de me revoir
moi aussi est ce que quelqu'un est venu
pendant que j'étais pas là habitants ont
reçu via les amis des accents
métalliques
c'est la fin de ce site une culture je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]